a little sign for debate club roll it up
I was a huge fan of The Simpsons didn't
really pay much attention to King and
Hill I know throw me in jail you want me
to I'll get a shitty mail but then I
start reading something king of the hill
and realized there was that show was a
lot more funnier than I give credit for
propane it got me thinking because I was
under ready because I was underrated
what do you guys think was to better
anime show Simpsons or king of the hill
I'll leave you to go on fight duke it
out gang gang claws buzz drip drip drip
drip that's Derek King a hill was weak
is fun orders to stand by a fence for
[ __ ] ten seasons
dude The Simpsons all they did sit on a
couch they killed a dude and they
predicted the future from Trump winning
the area 51 Simpsons don't have a cow
man come on bro Lisa Simpson eat my
shorts boy do mr. burns I think that
shit's on both amends Family Guy family
yep okay misleading I think it's kind of
bizarre The Simpsons was good when
Santa's Little Helper was really popping
off if I could decline baby never grew
up
yeah what the baby's name was much that
large was the mom will be Maggie Maggie
we suck dude time to get rid of the Baba
the sucker she had on for 10 years yeah
dude claim when you [ __ ] have that
thing in your mouth
I don't trust that crusty a clown around
the kids either
pedophile with makeup on all the goddamn
tonight he was awesome dude
Montgomery burns the senior citizen that
wouldn't die a lot of good characters
Ned Flanders man oh yeah Oh Ned Flanders
body hub howdy neighbor
what about the guy though what about the
hot daughter on king of the hill I'm not
familiar with Kenya anyone else in here
no cuz we're goddamn money or summer
name was titty Jenny
Louanne sorry were you a cure you were
king and he'll fin yeah let's see that
king of the hill cast man let's see a
[ __ ] decent looking king of the hill
just turned into f is for family exact
same show but bill Burgess me that way
that hot daughter bro mmm-hmm she's a
Christina Applegate of our generation
you Bach muppet state can still get it
look at that frickin uh we got [ __ ] dog
he gets a [ __ ] on my face Simpsons
destroys this and I'm really competition
I thought they're gonna say Family Guy
Simpson what do you think their wanker
Bain bro
king of the hill pretty decent I'll say
that only baby do you had in your town I
don't know anyone who likes freakin king
of the hill did I ask a king of day all
right bro whatever did well what's the
fan say seventy seventy four percent
Simpsons Wow of course Inspector Gadget
was [ __ ] good though do the same [ __ ]
yeah dude and they made that busted
Matthew broad reading or where the [ __ ]
his name is remember and he was
Inspector Gadget sounds horrible it was
awful dude remember the big guy with the
cat and a metal arm yeah he's always
like rubbing his cat a Vietnam veteran
yet and just pissed yeah I don't know
what in spirit togethers trying to solve
every goddamn episode you the worse dude
look just admit you're trying to [ __ ]
Carmen Sandiego and chill bro yeah dude
you're searching for her let's get out
of this topic man
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]